He wears a diaper just like you do.
(bouncy music)
My name is Adam and this
is my little girl Samantha.
And this is her favorite stuffed animal.
You give Mono big hugs?
Aw, give Mono kisses?
You like monkey?
What does the monkey say?
Uh uh.
That's right, and today I'm
going to do a magic trick
and turn it into a real animal for her.
(mischievous percussion)
(baby talk)
Hi, Nano, that's right, that's Nano.
Mono is Spanish for monkey
and she pronounces it Nano.
All right, are you ready?
Mmhmm.
All right, you want to close your eyes,
you want to play peekaboo with Nano?
Yeah.
Yeah? All right.
Peekaboo, close your eyes.
(magical whoosh sound)
Okay, one, two, three, peekaboo.
(baby talk)
Who's that?
What is that?
Nano.
That's right, that's a monkey.
What does a monkey say?
Look at the monkey go.
(sound of Samantha giggling)
Do you like the monkey, is he doing tr...
Is he doing funny tricks?
- [Samantha] Yeah.
Yeah, look at him go.
Say hi, monkey.
Hi (giggles).
Oop, there he goes.
There he goes.
(baby fussing)
Nano.
There's Nano.
Do you love Nano?
Yeah.
Yeah, there he is.
There's the monkey.
You just want at it real bad, don't you?
Is the monkey eating?
- [Samantha] Uh huh.
Yeah.
Nano.
Hi, Nano, say hi, Nano.
Up, yeah, the monkey
went up, that's right.
Careful.
All right, let's say bye bye.
Say bye bye.
Bye.
Here we go, one, two, three,
(magical whooshing sound)
and then boop, there's
monkey, there's Nano.
So this was awesome for me.
I could tell that she
really liked the monkey.
She just kept trying to get
at it and give him big hugs,
like she does with her stuffed animal.
I don't know if she bought the fact
that the animal switched
into the monkey or not,
but she had a good time.
Until we took the monkey away, of course.
(baby fussing)
Okay, okay.
(energetic music)